KIMBER LOCKHART:
Thank you, Rebecca.
And thank you also to Reena.
All your efforts
to drive engagement
with high school
students and younger
make a better pipeline for
me to hire from tomorrow.
So thank you very much for that.
About me, I'm at Box.
If you're not
familiar with Box, we
make it very easy
for enterprises
to manage their content and
collaborate with each other.
We're replacing a
lot of legacy tools
that these companies had
to use for security reasons
with a really high-security
model built in the cloud.
I'm here to talk about a
near and dear topic to me,
and that is moving into
engineering leadership.
And why is this topic
so near and dear to me?
Well, I have to tell
you my story in order
to tell you that.
So I ended up declaring
computer science
at Stanford a little
bit accidentally.
If I didn't declare
accidentally,
I definitely stayed in because
the chair of the department
wouldn't let me out.
He's like, we've got one,
and she's going to stay here.
So I got through
those early classes.
Even though I wanted
to quit several times,
there I was at the end-- a
computer science diploma.
And I got swept up in the
Silicon Valley entrepreneurship
craze.
So a couple of friends of
mine and I started a company.
We ended up taking a seed
round of funding from DFJ
three months before I graduated.
Now, talk about a stressful
final quarter at college.
We're starting this company.
We're sitting on, you
know, millions of dollars
in the bank-- never even
seen that much money--
and trying to
figure out how we're
going to get the right
level of market traction
to make our company successful.
We're also fighting the market.
This was 2008, 2009.
This was not a nice time to
be a startup, but we did it.
We ran the company for
about a year and a half.
We built technology
that allowed you
to see a document
in your browser--
so like a Word doc
or a PowerPoint.
Now we can do that every
day, but at that time
it just was not available.
Turns out, the
up-and-coming company Box
really needed that technology.
So we got a call from Aaron and
Dylan, the founders, one day.
And we came in and
we started talking,
and we decided that we were
going to have Box acquire us
so that we could power
their document viewing.
All right.
So I'm joining Box.
I'm, like, seventh
engineer at Box.
And I had to learn to go from
being an entrepreneur to being
an individual contributor
engineer at Box.
What I did well was
lead groups of teams.
So when we wanted a
JavaScript style guide,
we had a JavaScript style guide
because I got all my buddies
together and we made one.
And so my boss corners
me one day and says,
Kimber, do you want to be
an engineering manager?
Our team is growing,
and we need one.
I looked back at
him, and I said, no.
That sounds a lot
like middle manager,
and I hear that's really
a weird thing to be.
Maybe you get stuck
there forever,
and you don't actually get
to be a leader because you're
this manager person.
Went home, thought about it,
changed my mind, came back.
Said, I'm stuck here in my
golden handcuffs anyway,
might as well give it a shot.
And I make possibly the
best decision of my life,
and I move into this
management spot.
And what was so
cool about that is,
this is the time Box's
engineering group
is growing and
growing aggressively.
So I had four people on my team.
And then I had 20
people on my team.
And then I had 40
And I was bringing
up new managers,
and then I had 60
people on my team.
And I had to learn to
scale incredibly quickly.
And I had to learn
a lot of the lessons
that I want to share with
you guys the hard way.
I also had the opportunity
to bring about eight people
from my team and other teams
at Box into engineering
leadership, both
managerial and technical.
I'll get to the
distinction in a second.
But I was able to bring
these people into engineering
leadership, and you
know the great part?
Three of those eight
people were women.
And so now my
management team at Box
is actually half women,
which is pretty cool.
All right.
So what I'm going to share
today is some common themes
on the path to
engineering leadership.
Things that if you
know them will help you
as you decide what
you're going to do.
So the first is to aim clearly.
There is the old
and kind of cliched
statement that if you don't
know what you're going for,
how do you get there.
It's true, but it's especially
true in the engineering world.
And here's why.
What I have up here is
not exactly what Box does,
but it's close.
It's a pretty
general graph of how
people get promoted
through an engineering
organization of any size at all.
And so what you can see at the
top is the management track.
So you might start out
as a software engineer,
do what I did-- say, hey maybe
this management thing would
be pretty cool, and move on
up, and all of a sudden you're
VP of engineering.
It doesn't quite work like that.
There's a second row that's
same prestige-- in fact,
at Box it's actually probably
more prestigious than going up
the management track-- which
is the technical track.
And so these are your elite
technical contributors.
It turns out, the sort
of horizontal alignment
is on purpose.
Roughly, if you are a
very high-level engineer,
you are paid the
same, you're valued
the same as your very top
engineering leadership.
This is pretty standard.
At the bottom I just
have another track
that sometimes people
will use if you're
specializing in design
or architecture.
To make this more
confusing, I have not even
included product or
program management.
And those are often tracks that
engineers will go down as well.
So when I say aim
clearly, I don't
mean that you have to
know what you want to do.
But I'm saying that you should
probably pick one at a time.
Pick one you want to go
to, decide what it is.
If you want to change
your mind, fine.
But at least you're doing
all the right things
to get you in that direction.
Because what it takes to
become a VP of engineering
is different from what
it takes to become
a principal architect.
And that's all very
different from what
it takes to move into
product management.
All right.
So you've got to figure
out what you want to do.
Now, it's a really common thing
that my direct reports will
come to me and say, I don't
know what I want to do.
I haven't decided yet.
And that's fine.
That's my job to have a
conversation with them
about what they want to
do with their future.
The problem comes when they
don't follow up with me,
and say a couple
weeks later, actually
I decided I want to go
down the technical track.
Can you help me find the
right opportunities to do so?
If they spend forever
sort of straddled
between the technical track
and the managerial track,
not only can I not
help them-- if they
try to get promoted to
one of these two sides,
they won't have been
doing the right thing.
So the point of this is, pick
where you're going to go.
Change it when you
want to change it.
But always have sort of
a singular destination.
All right.
Next, be at the right
place at the right time.
I happen to use
a picture of Box.
You could use a picture of
any of a handful of companies.
What's important here is
not that Box was small
when I joined but
rather that Box
was growing extremely quickly.
So what do you guys think is
the right profile to join?
Let's say you want to become
an engineering manager,
and you're exhibiting leadership
as a software engineer.
What's kind of the
best company to go to?
Anybody have any ideas?
No ideas?
Something rapidly growing.
More specifically, you're
going to be looking
for teams that are
hitting 8, 10 people, that
are hiring very aggressively.
Because we all want to
promote from inside.
And so if we can hire you
as a software engineer,
and you start to show
great leadership,
we want to promote you-- not
only do we want to, we need to.
We actually have this
desperate need for leaders.
And that's a very
different environment
than being in a company
where the spot of manager
of your team is filled, and
you don't get to move up
until that person quits or
gets promoted or whatever else.
You don't want to be
in that situation.
So there's a little bit
of strategic alignment
with the company and the
phase of your career based
on what it is that
you're aiming for.
Do the job before you have it.
Our cute little doctor friend
here is a good example,
but I want to tell you a story.
When I was in high school, I
went out for the track team.
I had been injured the year
before in eighth grade track,
so I didn't have a reputation
for being very fast
or for being a great
runner in high school.
And when the coach
first came out
with the roster for the team,
I looked down the varsity side.
I looked for my name.
I kept looking for my name.
And my name was
not on that side.
And I looked over on the JV
side, and my heart sinks.
And I'm a junior varsity runner
in the 100-meter dash, which
is code for, we don't
know what you do,
but you're not very fast.
I get to looking at the
varsity side again, though,
and there's an opening.
And that opening is in
the 400-meter hurdles.
Yeah, that is a great
face, right over there.
400-meter hurdles has
the scariest reputation
of, I think, any
race in, at least,
Iowa high school girls track.
It's killer-- you're sprinting
the whole time, jumping over
things, you turn
green at the end.
It's awful.
But I really wanted
to run varsity track.
So I went to my coach,
and I said, hey Coach,
I noticed there's a spot here.
Could I take it?
She's like, if you want to, OK.
So I do it, and I run the
race, and I almost die.
And I don't do
particularly well.
But the next time
the roster comes out,
guess whose name is next
to 400-meter hurdles
in the varsity column?
Mine.
Got progressively better over
the course of the season.
And the most important
thing is that I lettered
in varsity high school
track my freshman year.
I'm a little competitive, so
this was very important to me.
And what was cool about that
was that what I had done
is found a way to do
the job before I had it.
I did the job before
I was officially
a member of the high
school track team.
So there's this
common misperception
that you can't do this
in leadership, especially
on the management track.
What are you going to do?
Take your peers, sit
across at a table,
and deliver an annual review?
I wouldn't recommend it.
So you can't-- you can't
deliver an annual review.
But if you aren't able to
enable people to do better work,
if you're not able to
solve problems that
affect the entire
team, and if you're not
able to get things done when
you promised to get them done
without authority,
you're never going
to be able to do those
things with authority.
In fact, the best leaders
I've ever come upon rarely
touch their authority.
They rely on the
influence that they
learned before they
officially had the role
to get the job done.
So do that.
Observe someone who's doing
the job that you want.
See what they do.
See what problems
they're trying to solve.
Solve problems that
are "above your level."
Find your 400-meter hurdles,
and get yourself in the race.
All right, you're doing
the job beforehand.
What else is important?
Well, there's this
constant tension, I think,
with engineers.
Does someone want
to raise your hand
and give me what I
mean by leverage?
Anybody?
Over there.
AUDIENCE: What you can
use to position yourself
in a situation to get a
more positive outcome.
KIMBER LOCKHART:
More positive outcome
is the most important
part of that definition.
So how to focus
on the things that
have the highest impact for
the littlest amount of work.
And so when we're
talking to people
who are moving into leadership,
what we always ask them to do
is think about
focusing their time
on high-leverage activities.
This is what you do if you
hire a housecleaner to clean
your house so that you can spend
more time working on your job
or taking care of your kids.
So high-leverage
activities are very
important if you
want to move up.
At the same time, there's
a trap on the other end
of the spectrum where
you get so focused
on high-leverage activities that
you forget that sometimes it's
the little things that makes
the company the most successful.
So the phrase I like
to use to capture this
is think high leverage but be
willing to take out the trash.
When I was at Increo,
we didn't have someone
to take out the
trash for a while.
So, you know, the little
bitty Ikea trash cans
we had in our office
started to fill up quite far
with M&M wrappers and
Diet Dr. Pepper bottles.
And eventually I
took out the trash
because somebody had
to do it or nobody
would want to come
to work every day.
And so that's really the kind
of thing you need to focus on.
When you have an opportunity to
serve your team, you take it.
Now what's probably
the most important here
is that your mantra
should be, what
is best for the business
over the long term?
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, could
you give us examples
of high-leverage activities?
KIMBER LOCKHART:
It's a good question.
So a high-leverage
activity might be something
like, instead of
personally deciding
that you like a new
JavaScript stockpile
and fixing a file to include
that JavaScript file,
you might get a group
of people together
to think about what should
be the new JavaScript
style for everything
and enable all of them
to be working on the same
thing at the same time.
It's the difference
between fixing a little bug
and introducing a
framework that removes
all instances of that bug.
Sometimes fixing the
little bug is the choice.
More often than not, removing
all future instances of the bug
is the right choice.
So the way to really
think about it
is, what is going to be best for
your company in the long term.
And if you can make
decisions according to that--
and sometimes those decisions
involve taking out the trash,
involve working on the sexiest,
highest-leverage
architecture project
there is-- you're going
in the right direction.
All right.
Last but not least,
welcome feedback.
So you know that
feeling when somebody
gets to the areas for
improvement section?
Your heart sinks, starts beating
faster, you're really nervous.
What are they going to say?
You go into fight
or flight mode.
You even like the person sitting
across the table from you,
and it's scary.
Getting feedback at any
time is extremely scary.
It's exposing our flaws
and our vulnerabilities.
And it can be very easy
when you get feedback
to shut down, to agree with
it, to disagree with it,
to fight back about it.
Turns out none of those are
the appropriate response
for getting more feedback.
What feedback gives you
is the ability to improve.
And the more you move
up in your career,
the more you rely upon feedback
to tell you how to improve,
because there's
not a set of rules.
In my job right now,
a measure of success
is how well is your team doing.
Well, that's not like did I
write more code or less code.
That's a really hard
thing to define.
So the way that I improve
is by getting feedback.
Now the way you
get more feedback
is to respond to
feedback as follows.
Thank you.
And that's it.
So what you want
to do is you want
to be the person that no
matter what, when someone comes
to you with feedback,
you say thank you.
You attempt to implement
it, and you move on.
And that's the kind of thing
that has people come to you
and tell you about things that
might be your blind spots.
It might be your limiting
factors in the future.
So as much as your
heart starts to sink,
and as much as your
stomach gets tight,
just remember-- thank you.
It's all you have to say.
Now, the other side
of welcoming feedback
is putting that feedback to use.
So obviously, if
you're defensive when
you get feedback,
people are going
to stop coming to
you with feedback.
But if you don't ever
implement any of the feedback
that you receive, people also
will be a little bit less
willing to come to you
with that feedback.
So one of my favorite
strategies on implementing
the feedback you
receive, especially
with a group of people,
is called feedforward.
And it's Marshall
Goldsmith's concept
from his book "What Got You
Here Won't Get You There."
And he spends a
lot of time talking
about saying thank you
when you get feedback.
But taking the team of
people you work with,
including your boss,
and engaging them
in helping you get better.
So what feedforward is is you
decide-- you get some feedback,
you decide about something
you want to work on.
Let's say you want to
become a better listener.
So you go to all of the
people that you work with
and you say, I'm trying
to be a better listener.
Do you have ideas for how I
might be a better listener?
Then they give you an idea.
And how do you respond?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KIMBER LOCKHART:
Thank you, excellent.
You say thank you.
Take it or leave it,
implement it or don't.
But the benefit of this is
that your team, your boss,
the people you work
with, know that you're
aiming for improvement
in this way.
OK?
So it can be really hard to
deal with feedback, especially
when it comes from your boss or
your peers and it's not fair.
But it's so important that
you develop a reputation
as someone who welcomes
feedback in order
to continue to move
up in your career.
Last but not least-- your
job's going to change.
In the words of
the Red Queen, you
have to do more and more just
to stay in the same place.
And this is true.
When I went from being
an entrepreneur to being
an individual
contributor developer,
I suddenly had to
learn how to code
with a whole group of people.
And then when I went from being
a developer to being a manager,
all of a sudden
my success was not
based on how well I did-- I
could do the coolest project
ever-- it was based on
how well my team did.
And then when I moved
to managing managers,
all of a sudden
how my team did was
a given, that had
to be successful.
My success was based
on the type of change
that I could bring to
the entire organization.
In fact, my underlying
advice for all of this
is that at any given
time, consider yourself
your boss's secret partner.
Like, right now I'm the co-VP of
engineering, but nobody knows.
And then you're
solving the types
of problems that will get
you to the next level.
So as you move up
in your career,
success will increasingly
be about your ability
to find the problems
and then solve it.
All right.
So we're going to move
to questions here.
You've got my five
pieces of advice.
If you'd like to connect
with me at any point--
@kimber_lockhart.
Might take me a few days.
I'm not really into Twitter.
My co-founder now works at
Twitter, so he made me do it.
In any case, please take
some time, ask me a question.
I'm happy to share any more
about any of these things
or some examples of how I've
seen these topics be really
useful for the people
that are on my team.
Thank you guys.
Do we have a-- there it is.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the great presentation.
So you kind of
mentioned sometimes
we need to pick a route.
What if there is
two routes to pick.
How would we go--
let's say, manager,
like engineer manager,
and program manager,
or product management.
So haven't done none of those.
I'm kind of trying to decide
which one I'm better at.
How would I pick it?
KIMBER LOCKHART:
Do you do-- yes.
She would like to know if there
are two routes, say engineering
program manager and
what was the other one?
Engineering manager?
AUDIENCE: Product manager.
KIMBER LOCKHART:
Product manager.
OK, so if there's several
different similar routes,
how do you pick?
I can't answer that
for you because that's
a very personal question.
But do your due diligence
and settle on one for now.
Set a calendar reminder
six months in the future
to see if you'd like
to change your mind.
And then don't worry about it.
And do everything
you possibly can
to hit the route that
you picked at this time.
Because the people that
are most successful
are not really the ones who
are, from what I've seen,
are not really the ones
who are absolutely sure,
but they're the ones who
can pick enough so that they
do the right things
to get to the level
where they can decide
whether they like it.
It's much easier to
move horizontally
than it is to move sort
of up in the world.
AUDIENCE: My question
to you is what
personal obstacles or the
most important obstacle you
had to face to be
where you are now?
And how did you overcome it.
KIMBER LOCKHART:
The question is,
what are the most
important obstacles
I had to face to get where I am
now, and how did I overcome it?
Life is a series of
obstacles, right?
But one I will call
out is learning
how to manage
managers-- learning
how to promote
your first manager.
That was actually
extremely difficult.
There's not a rule book on how
to find your first manager.
And so what I did at that
time is I went to my boss,
I went to some industry
connections that I had,
and I said, I would
like to meet someone
who has been through
exactly the same thing I'm
going through--
company hypergrowth--
in a different company
about three years ago.
Who do you know?
Of course, they introduced
me to all women,
but these are fantastic women.
And they took me through how
you hire your first manager.
They took me through how
you evaluate whether or not
that's working.
And they really helped me
to get to that next stage
of my career.
So when you hit some
of these obstacles,
it's a good time to say, I
need to learn as much as I can.
And you might learn from books,
you might learn from mentors,
but don't hesitate to reach out
for introductions to people who
have done exactly what it
is that you want to do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So why be an engineering leader.
KIMBER LOCKHART:
It's a good question.
You don't have to be.
But being in
engineering leader--
either a technical leader or
a management-style leader--
gives you more impact than
you can have as an individual.
So there is nothing I like more
than seeing a team that I've
built, people that
I've put together,
that are more successful
than the sum of their parts.
It fulfills me.
And so if it's not the kind
of thing that you like doing,
give it a try, decide you
don't like it, that's great.
But there's something
very special about having
more impact by
working with a team--
either giving them
people leadership
or giving them
technical direction--
that you just don't
get as an individual.
AUDIENCE: So in terms of the
leadership and management,
do you see any advantages
that women have more than men,
and how can we leverage
that advantages?
KIMBER LOCKHART:
It's a good question,
do women have more
advantages than men?
You know, I think it's a wash.
There are some things that have
been incredibly beneficial.
People like to write about
women in computer science,
I've found.
So I get way more PR than
my male counterparts--
kind of cool.
But on the other hand,
I'll be in discussions
and you'll see
some of the things
that Sheryl Sandberg
shares in "Lean In"
where women are perceived
as more emotional or more
aggressive than
they actually are.
I've seen that in the workplace.
And ultimately, you are an
individual, you are unique,
you have strengths,
you have weaknesses.
Who you are, what
your gender is,
is just another
dimension of that.
And I'd say, not worry about.
And if you believe
that it will be a wash
and that you're
just as likely to be
as successful as
any other person,
I think you're more
likely to get there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Kimber.
So my question is as
a junior developer
who just got out of
college, if I kind of want
to be a manager in
the future, what
are the specific steps
or advice I can use.
Let's say I mean a relatively
big company where there
are managers, there
are a lot of managers.
So what are the things I
can do to go to that point.
KIMBER LOCKHART: Absolutely.
So if you're a junior
developer, what kinds of things
can you do?
Well, one is to get
really good at your job.
So a lot of moving
into leadership
is based on being good
at what you do now.
It's a prerequisite,
it's not everything.
Another thing that
you might do is really
observe the behavior of
the managers and leaders
that you look up to.
Another thing you might do is
notice where there's problems.
Engineers are problem solvers
by nature but so many of us
don't take the time to go
outside of the code, outside
of the project, and see that
this process is really broken.
I can probably fix it.
And it's that level
of considering
yourself empowered to solve
organizational problems that
will make you into a person
that people start to notice,
and will start to get you into
more and more leadership roles.
Any other questions?
There we go.
AUDIENCE: In your
leadership journey,
what is it that you
know now that you
wish you had known
10 years back?
KIMBER LOCKHART:
Most of the things
I just shared with
you, actually.
When I was making
this presentation,
I said what do I wish I knew?
And it was a lot
of those things.
The overarching thing I wish
I knew-- I was in college.
And I was trying to
determine if I wanted
to be a product
manager or an engineer.
Anybody ever wrestled with that?
Yeah, it tends to be a pretty
typical thing, especially
in the women in tech circles.
And I wish I would have known
that engineering leadership,
engineering management, becoming
a director of engineering,
running whole engineering
teams, was a viable career path.
Because it achieves
a lot of what
I like in terms of
interacting with people,
and marries it with still
being extremely technical.
I may not write code every
day, but I'm sitting in there,
I'm making decisions, I'm
asking the hard questions.
So I wish that I knew that this
career path existed, because I
would have saved a whole lot of
time wrestling with what else
I wanted to do.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So for someone who is starting
out as a software engineer,
you tend to actually go
on the technical part
because you are shielded
off from so many things
if you just stay
this way, and you
get to do what
you like the most.
But with someone with
that mindset, what
is the one thing
that you would say
is the brightest side
of just moving up
on to the management part.
KIMBER LOCKHART: So if
you love what you do,
I'm not sure I'd be overly
concerned about doing something
different.
That's sort of my guide.
At the same time, if you are
scared of doing something else,
that's your first red flag that
maybe you should consider it.
And if you live your
life according to that,
you're probably going to
be in pretty good shape.
AUDIENCE: So you talked a
little bit about how it's easier
to move horizontally
than vertically,
but as you climb up those levels
of leadership, if at some point
you realize that
it's not what you
want to do but you know
that now, at this point,
you've got teams upon teams
resting upon your decision,
does it become more
difficult in any way
to shift and to change
entirely what you want to do,
if you take that leap and
you climb all the way up?
KIMBER LOCKHART: There's sort of
two answers that I'll give you.
One is that if you
have the opportunity
to move into management, and
you want to give it a try,
and that's what you've set your
aim on, by all means do it.
If your company knows
what they're doing,
they will have a track back out.
It's very typical that engineers
will think that this is
something they want to do and
then get into it and either
decide they love
it or really don't.
I have two people
on my team actually
who have become managers
that I have transitioned
back out to individual
contributors.
Not because they
were doing a bad job,
but because it was clear
in our conversations
that there just was not a fit.
They didn't like it, and
they weren't as effective
as they could have been
if they did like it.
Now to your question of
moving further up and what
you do when you move further up.
I think what's really
nice about our industry is
that opportunities are
so plentiful that you
can kind of do
whatever you want.
But it does become
harder to make
a move when you
have a large team.
So as you start to have
bigger and bigger teams,
you have to have more
specific plans for what
happens if you need to extract
yourself from that situation.
So that might mean, you've
been there for 10 years,
you want to do
something else, it's
time for you to move on
to your next opportunity.
You are measured by how
you leave your team.
And so leaving your
team in great shape
is something that follows
you as you move on.
AUDIENCE: You've
talked a lot about sort
of moving through
your career and how
things change over time.
And 10 years into my
career I'm realizing
that I evaluated whether I
was doing the right things
or whether I wanted
to change things
a lot more earlier in
my career than I do now.
And so the question
I have is, how often
do you think it's
healthy to really look
at what you're doing
and sort of reality
check yourself in the
direction that you're
going as you progress
through your career,
and how do you change
that over time?
KIMBER LOCKHART: So
most of these answers
have been solely my opinion.
This one is perhaps
even more so.
This is just what I do.
I find that if I go
longer than six months,
I haven't thought
about it enough.
If I go less long than six
months, I drive myself crazy.
So I ended up at six months.
You could try your birthday
every year, try New Year's.
New Year's is great,
because you get
to set goals and think about
your life all at the same time.
Favorite holiday.
But I do recommend
having some frequency
that you evaluate what it
is you're doing, especially
because you can
get in a situation
where you're not making a
move because you're scared
of the next move, as opposed
to because you're really
happy with what you're doing.
And really, that's the
time to be concerned.
If you're happy doing what
you're doing, have at it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Have you ever in your
career have seen women
not moving up in the
hierarchy because people
in the management thinks
that they are-- because she
is a woman and she needs
time with her family,
and she may not be able to give
hundred percent to this job
profile?
Have you ever come
across this situation?
KIMBER LOCKHART: No.
Not explicitly.
Have I ever come across
women paying a penalty
in moving up in the ladder
because they might want
to spend more time with their
children and their family?
Usually I see it
more the other way
around, where women don't
approach the opportunity
or don't plan for
the opportunity
because they're
worried about it.
And I'm lucky.
I work at an extremely
thoughtful company,
an extremely supportive
company of women.
And I got to form that
from a very early stage.
But if you look at-- my
leadership team is half women.
In fact, the team that I'm
a part of, the team that
sort of reports to the head
of engineering is half women.
I honestly don't know
how that came to be,
but it's an extremely exciting
dynamic to be a part of.
And actually what I
find is, of the women
that stay in technical
roles, many of them
have other sides to
their personality
that make them good leaders.
So this is by all means not
a sweeping, generalization
statement.
There are people of all
profiles of all genders,
but I keep accidentally
having women
move into leadership
roles on my team
because they keep
being the people who
are good at organizing
other people.
So actually, I had to
go in, and at one point
I had all women
as Scrum Masters,
and somebody came
to me and said,
do you realize you have this?
And I said, no, I didn't
realize I had that.
Maybe I should
encourage some guys.